[Musique]
je
sais pas du bien surtout ses paroles
voilà ça fait du bien à mon âme car il
est jeune et Dieu
[Musique]
j'ai toujours rêvé d'être un artiste
mais je savais pas que je devais le
faire pour le Seigneur
m'a dit Jésus peut t'aider à sortir de
tes vis il peut te donner une nouvelle
vie faut juste faire une prière les
sortir les filles
bon la cigarette tout ça donc c'est des
choses que j'avais tellement voulu
arrêter mais j'en avais jamais eu la
force et la capacité donc quand on te
propose une main qui peut t'aider à
sortir de ça tu peux tu ne peux que la
tenir et vraiment ça a été radical ma
conversion j'ai tout arrêté d'un coup
persévérer
[Musique]